we we have a guest we have a guest
joining us
um the guy who
who told his Governor to go [__] himself
Ian Smith what's going on man thanks for
being on
that's a hell of an introduction I like
that intro uh how are you guys doing
good man doing good how you doing
that couldn't be better yeah I mean
obviously so you own a gym right yeah I
expected him to be more muscular
you are a [__] you're a machine dude
you're a goddamn animal it was funny I
came back from from my very healthy
cigarette and uh my pre-workout and uh I
came up and he was on the screen but
we're still off the air everyone's just
like oh he's on the screen and we were
both like oh he's like Jesus [__]
Christ look at that [__] guy I'm like
yeah man holy [__] so I I gotta at least
look the part [__] animal dude so
yeah we were following you very early
yeah we were covering this like this was
happening
uh so can you give uh I mean you know
our fans kind of know but give a little
background maybe that's how this kind of
started because I mean we know your
story obviously yeah man
um
well the short version you know uh my
business partner and I we're two regular
guys you know this is uh regular jokes
we were I mean we were two guys he owned
a nutrition store before me I was a
personal trainer a strength coach and
you know we got together and we said uh
we should probably open a gym and we did
uh we bought this dumpster fire of a gym
that was like six months behind on its
rent but we had the vision so you know
we uh the Apollo created Jim yeah
Rocky goes to train with Apollo crew
yeah I mean it was in back
behind on all its rent it was like it
was in bad condition and we turned it
around overnight because we you know we
put everything into it nine months later
you know they tell us to come shut our
doors and it's like
what like what do you what do you mean
you know what I mean like we just we
just dedicated a year of our life to
making this happen and you're just gonna
say you know what I'll just shut it for
14 days but you know we didn't
unfortunately at the time we didn't know
enough to confidently say [__] you right
we were thinking that you know but at
the end of the day no you know I don't
want to hurt anybody and it was like
they were showing us videos of the
Chinese people dropping dead in the
streets and and you know it was it was
the hysteria of the time so
we shot our doors but
um very clearly you know Common Sense
kicked in
um Koba didn't make sense no matter
which way you cut it whether it was the
political [__] or whether that they were
you know the the health stuff that they
were suppressing so
you know we paid attention to that if
you're gonna come into our lives and
you're going to say you know shut it
down then I want to know who you are and
I want to know what I'm so afraid of and
it was like all right so we're going to
pay attention to politicians and we're
going to pay attention to the science
just neither added up you know
politicians it was Politics as Usual
they were pumping the uh the ball back
and forth and you know they said there'd
be help and there was no help and then
bam all of a sudden they spend 2.3
trillion dollars on the 11th day of the
shutdown you know
giving people money everybody knows the
story yeah it didn't make sense so uh
you know Frank said Frank's my my
partner and he said uh you know they're
not going to open us and I said that you
know I don't think so either because
there was no plan to reopen nobody was
even talking about reopening on day 11
so he said well he's like we're gonna
have to open the gym and and for us it
was a simple Choice man like we were
watching businesses go out of business
in the first couple weeks you know and
you're not going to take that from me
you know it's just
yeah I don't think people at the time a
lot of those business owners didn't open
I don't think they realized the gravity
of the situation like they were just
trying to bury their heads in the sand
you know and hope to come out on the
other side of it and it's like man we're
not going to come out on the other side
of it there's three gyms in a five mile
radius that have already closed their
doors after the first couple weeks you
know what I mean because it's not cheap
to run a business well well and and the
other thing to add to that is is also
it's the same thing that happened during
covet with every small business it's
like the only people that could afford
to do that out is like Planet Fitness
could afford to it because they're a
mega conglomerate Walmart could afford
not to close Amazon didn't have to close
so they they they were fine they got
special exemptions and then when we you
know like all the employment rates back
up when you come back it's a bunch of
[__] planet fitnesses Walmarts and
everyone that's all you have and then
you go back to the crush that that was
the beautiful thing that they did is
they kneecapped small business and they
opened up the field for all the big
corporations to gobble up all that
business because people didn't stop
spending money you know what I mean yeah
and in any industry you look at right so
look at the the health club industry the
gym industry they shut down all these
small gems these big gems could make it
and then who else comes into the picture
big companies like Peloton and all these
you know all these companies that sell
like at-home technology and stuff and it
was a free pass for these guys to walk
into the industry like that [__]
wouldn't have even sold on the market in
2019.
it's true and everybody knows home gym
stuff [__] sucks yeah yeah it's it's
a gimmick yeah it's just it's it's the
evolution of uh what's the thing Chuck
Norris used to sell a body by Chuck
remember that thing or what was the
other one the gazelle the guy with the
ponytail that you saw that gazelle thing
yeah and it's true and [__] everything
and then the other problem is what was
the single biggest transfer of wealth in
history it was like it was disgusting
how much money shifted out of
everybody's hands and it just went right
to Jeff Bezos right to Bill States went
right to the Pfizer modern execs it was
disgustingly flagrant and I now I didn't
even realize when you opened up your gym
like because you know obviously we like
many people in the country were
introduced to you from people sharing
your story and sharing your video so we
kind of just plugged into your story a
little like you know late we didn't know
the background I didn't know you only
had the gym for like nine months like
nine months that's even more [__] up
to me because it's like oh what does
this guy own a chain of gems well you
know tighten your waistband you know we
got a you know flatten the curve it's
like no we literally just got this place
operating and got the back rent paid and
it's like well too bad like that's fine
so so that so then so then you then you
then then you started getting the the
legal threats right
um and and one of my favorite things
that I didn't did you took the door off
the hinges right that was funny yeah
I always say long story short but no man
listen we got an hour
so you know we we we said all right
we're gonna open you know we're gonna
open the gym
um like come hell or high water we're
gonna open but we're gonna open in a way
that we we can take all the shots that
we're ready for anything that we're not
looking stupid so we spent the next six
weeks creating this like over-the-top
safety protocol that was so far above
and beyond what anybody was even having
to do that was open that it would be
ludicrous if you came to our business
and shut us down we had spray bottles in
the hand of every person who's gonna
walk in the door uh we distance every
single piece of equipment in the gym six
feet apart from the next one there was
markings on the [__] floor
um that were you know the open space so
people knew where to stand there was
capacity restrictions we were taking
people's temperatures and then we said
all right well you know I went on my
Instagram at the time it was a you know
I don't know there's a couple thousand
followers on it it was a fitness
Instagram and you know I said hey guys
you know um we're gonna open our gym
come next Monday you know here's why and
the video went viral you know and talked
across and called and then that was the
can of gas in the fire and we started
getting legal threats already like the
week before you know once I went on to
talk across and show and um the police
weren't supposed to let us in the door
so the series of events goes we locked
ourselves in the gym on Sunday night
locked ourselves in chained the doors
board um closed up the windows so you
couldn't see
and opened on Monday police were in the
parking lot it started off with
citations on day one then they uh they
started getting our members day two day
three they were pulling people over they
were arresting people
um there's one guy who got arrested
excuse me a couple who got threatened to
arrest a bunch of citations we got a
health department shut down
um and then we just kept going
Friday of the first week they came and
they physically locked our doors in the
middle of the night so they came with a
locksmith and sheriff and they changed
the locks on our doors and then we said
all right you know what
let's take it to court we made our
stands you know we made our Point let's
let's fight it out in court because you
know what you think of the American
system is that we have the three
branches to to you know to balance each
other out this was obviously the
executive branch running wild so let's
hand it over to the courts and let's see
what they do very clearly they weren't
going to do anything so we picked the
locks and we went back inside and opened
back up good
um yeah you know it was good no but
that's that well you're so good I mean
you were we tried to be nice every step
of the way it's the road it's the road
it's the road it's the Roadhouse method
if you've ever watched the movie
Roadhouse and Patrick Swayze gives that
speech when he's like be nice be nice
until it's time not to be nice and you
could you could try as much as you want
but at the end of the day it's your
livelihood and that's why that that's
like that first off I'm glad you brought
up a Tucker Carlson thing because it
felt Petty because Tucker Carlson right
before that happened he was talking [__]
about like as he should have about the
governor and then as soon as you went on
he was like I'm gonna destroy [__]
talking anybody who talks about me
because he couldn't go after Tucker
because he doesn't live in New Jersey
right so he was like I'm going after
anybody [__] he he really wants to be
he's a nerd that's the problem with it
all these [__] nerds are the what
should be shoved in lockers are the ones
that they get we saw covid show what
these [__] nerds did too they got any
power and all they wanted to say was
like you could have your booze but you
can't go to the [__] gym and you
can't do that we live in Florida so we
were kind of we had both yeah yeah I'm
like no I'm in Florida I'll have both
and I'll take a side order of guns yes
thank you I'm a side of guns please and
that's the problem too you live in
Jersey which I mean we talk on the show
a lot about how corrupt Chicago is how
corrupt New York how corrupt California
is I and haven't I you know I'm from New
York originally and I grew up like in
New York I don't think New York Jersey
ever gets enough credit for being as
corrupt as they are because it's so
close to New York well I grew up like in
the days of like John Corzine and like
just Christy like like these guys that
went back to like real like Sopranos era
Jersey so I can see why you have such
[__] up laws and they're like well no
we'll just beat you in the stomach with
[__] you know clubs until you
complain no no no no you're like all
right phone books because they don't
leave bruises phone books no you're
you're a veteran right like we're in the
Marines or at the grocery store no I
wasn't you're wearing a marine oh okay I
was in prison instead of the service oh
okay well that's just well that's that's
just it's tough though I mean no it's uh
there's a lot of similarities between
them that's why I say that it takes it
takes the same mentality to [__] just
fly out into the desert and just a
shitty little [__] Humvee and shoot
it like blindly into a sandstorm as it
does to flood your cell and take on
three cos right I mean it's the same
[__] go mode same shitty food you
know you're you're sleeping with a bunch
of [__] dudes in a bunk room that's
what you were doing with your gym during
covet he was doing the equivalent of
well take one my clothes and put them in
the toilet and then I'll just flush the
toilet ten thousand times and now three
you have to fight me well honestly the
prison prison might be prison might be
more honorable because you
fighting for the globalist in there
you know I would have been and I I
respect anybody who served but I I
wanted to serve and unfortunately I you
know I wound up in prison instead but I
I think about that all the time and I
think about that I'm actually glad that
I did you know because it's it's such an
honorable thing to serve your country
but in the capacity that our U.S
military is used today you know that's
why these guys come home with like with
with such heavy hearts because it's not
you know you're you're not fighting for
a good cause you know you're fighting
that you know at the uh you know for the
will of you know some rich Bankers
um and and that's that and that and we
say that too because we actually we have
a lot of merch between merch and I have
a lot of friends that serve them they
say the same thing they're like I'm
[__] bummed and they're like you know
a lot of people are like you they after
9 11 is really when everyone got
patriotic and rightfully so obviously
everyone got patriotic but then after a
while you're like okay but like
are we about to go to war with you like
in Russia like I don't know like who how
does that help people and then you're
like so you're sending people to die 19
year olds to [__] die for things that
don't matter and it's like okay now or
not well to them it matters like you
said bankers and their [__] right I mean
the only people that ever make [__]
money anyway are the
um
though any anybody in the military
industrial complex now you know Raytheon
always makes money you see the uh did
you see the Pat Tillman commercial
they're [__] the Super Bowl there's a
[__] there was a military commercial
who died in Atlanta Duty and everyone
was tweeting like yeah but how though
uh because some would say you know maybe
maybe got murdered because he was going
to do that interview Chomsky but
whatever he was gonna do that interview
too man [__] they [__] Tillman over so
hard yeah so it's it does suck like you
said I do know a lot of guys that like
even in our audience that tell us like
yeah I served and I was proud and like
you just see what's going on now and
it's like a lot of guys come home jaded
or they I mean they come home black
pilled or like at least red pilled
because they've they've seen or they've
had to do things and it's like man I
thought I was over here fighting for my
country this doesn't really feel like
fighting for Freedom as much as it feels
like but don't but don't worry about it
Mark Millie now is gonna give give us
all critical race Theory that's what
everybody wants right you know what they
what what what see military people even
though all what they tell me every time
I speak to him like we want dry socks
that's what they always say send me dry
socks please but in actually instead
what they're going to get it's a bunch
of critical race Theory books
to me the the US the U.S government
really doesn't represent our interests
anymore and I think that's where the
Divide comes from and it's like to me
the US government feels a lot like the
Jets front office right like every time
like there if you go online right you go
on YouTube it's very funny go on YouTube
Google Jets draft crowd reactions right
Montage that's right and like there's
like 20 years in a row where they're
like there's like [__] a super whole
like future Hall of Fame quarterback
first pick I know like the Jet draft
defensive tackle you know like dontarius
Jackson
and it's like it gets to a point where
the booze gets so loud but you just keep
doing the same [__] and you're like okay
the difference is we're paying you
trillions of dollars
quit after one day and he wrote it on a
piece of paper
just every year it's a funny poo and it
shakes the building and then it's like
nobody gets fired ever so it's the same
guys every year get to run it again so
yeah that's kind of that's a pretty good
metaphor actually because that's I mean
that's that's the United States
government
right now it's so bad dude no Matt no
matter how upset people get like they
just they go Full Speed Ahead oh right
into the next thing how many people
answer questions and walk away you get
30 million tweets tagging you going pick
this guy in the first round and then
they're like where do we want anyway and
you're like you [__] and it's
like but the difference is the Jets
aren't taking trillions of dollars from
you or asking me to die for them that's
a very good point you know yeah just
make me buy a jersey of a guy who's not
even no only only the Bulls do that
that's Hamlin I still have a Plaxico
burst Jersey what am I supposed to do
with that I ask that wait till he kills
somebody and then sell it that's my
guess self
sorry look we're not as we're not as
high brow as Tucker we're a bunch of
retards that's uh I've done them all
so um going back going back to what we
were talking about earlier so they
started with the fines first right they
started finding you it was at their
first
yeah I mean the citations were first and
then
um and weren't they like daily because
weren't they compounding I remember
seeing a video of you and you were like
so yeah we're up to like 180 Grand at
one point I was like Jesus no it gets
worse yeah okay so they they figured out
like they weren't gonna stop us so they
you know they the and all those
citations are meaningless it's a
violation of an executive order it's
like this archaic statue there's there's
not even any like punishment attached to
it's like a misdemeanor you know so they
gave us like 80 of them too we had like
a stack so
eventually they brought this judge in
and the judge brought a court order
against us and then said you know I'm a
judge I mandate you to shut down and we
said [__] you
um but then
because you violated court order now
they can attach like a tangible
punishment to it
um so they said the punishment was a 15
497.76 per day fine for every day that
we were open
and then he came out and said guys we're
gonna have to close on Sundays look I'm
trying to be reasonable here
all right six days a week I'm working
with you yeah so we we were taking
fifteen thousand dollar fines per day
they uh they started to hit our bank
account we walked into one day there was
like 200 000 from fundraising in there
and it's all going to lawyer fees anyway
it's done and that's donations because
we didn't charge anybody through any of
this you had did they let you have a
GoFundMe or did you use gifts and go
we our GoFundMe got attacked that's what
I was wanting to take it didn't get
taken down they froze the money and then
they let it stay and by the time you
know there was even time to to do
anything we had already gotten a pretty
sizable amount of money in the the rest
of the money we got because we weren't
charging memberships we were selling
T-shirts right so we were selling
T-shirts and people bought them in in
the most insane ways I mean we had same
shirt 40 different colors and people had
every single one of them and that was
the way people were paying memberships
whatever so they took two hundred
thousand dollars from our bank account
walked in one morning checked the bank
account zero dollars actually it was
negative six thousand because we had
just written a check
so they just they they yanked it right
out in the middle of long because we had
sued them you know and this is there's
legal [__] of course of course
um so we were in the middle of ongoing
litigation appealing these fines and
they just snatched 200 000 they hit us
with subpoenas for our personal finances
they came after they they took all the
money in my PayPal they took all the
money my venmo all the money in my cash
app
um all the money in my Apple cash that's
so [__] man how the government can
like they can fight you on two fronts
but you can't fight them you can't fight
yeah you can fight them in court but
then while you're spending all this
money in court they're like oh I can
also freeze all your [__] and it's like
[__] dude and fine and there's no and
there's no recourse so but what's crazy
and it's it's a cool part of the story
but it it highlights like why it worked
you know what I mean like you you said
in the beginning you said you know we
were introduced to your story you know
through somebody sharing it and if it
was just you know if the story hadn't
gone National we wouldn't have been able
to do it because we wouldn't have had
the resources so they hit us with that
[__] they took 200 000 I got right in
front of my phone like I did every day
you know my Instagram had become like
our emergency broadcast system
um because people would just share it I
mean anything I would put out hey guys
this is Ian at attilis this is the
update [__] 10 000 reshares in in 15
20 minutes it was like crazy so I said
hey uh here's the update from attilis
they just took you know 175 176 000 from
our bank account
um you know we don't know what we're
gonna do but [__] Gym's still open so
you guys here
and uh by the end of that week people
had purchased a hundred thousand dollars
in t-shirts that's Jesus that's good
that is a nice white pill though right
like at least knowing that no it is you
know it's like you know that's that
shows like if people can get their act
together behind something and it's and
it doesn't get hijacked and it's not
[__] and it's not [__] a psyop or
whatever the [__] you know comes down
the pike people can be very powerful
when they're you know when they're
marching together well that's a lot of
money in spite and there's a lot of
power in space that's true it's you know
there's a lot of stuff you know look
when the VAC thing came out right me and
Royce we were always of that school of
thought of like no we don't go out that
much as much as we used to anyway we're
mostly doing the shows you know you're
at the shows are you at the gym oh well
just you know what I'll wait I just
won't wait I'm not saying oh God they're
trying to put Nanobots in my [__]
brain stem but it was like let's just
you know let's see what let's see what's
the first round [__] let's see what
those gerbils yeah see if their brains
don't explode and then by the time time
we would even have imagined considering
it they started getting so [__] pushy
and crazy about it I said [__] yeah you
know it's a Spite and then we went no no
no no no no no now just no [__] you
because yeah no I'm out of spite no if
you're telling me I'm anti-vaxx yeah now
I'm an anti-vaxxer if the cops came in
here right now like I don't want a steak
right now if the cops walked in there
and said you are not permitted to have a
stake for the next 25 I want a steak the
only thing I want is a [__] steak
don't tell me what to do and I think
that that's there's some I don't know
that is the white pill is that there's a
significant portion of uh people that
I've seen on her belly is still like
like most of Florida was just like even
during the two weeks of lockdown Bars
were open yeah people were going out
even though everyone we were never
really locked down like certain counties
were like we're not shutting down and
the sheriffs are like we're not
enforcing that do whatever the [__] do
you want we don't care we're walking
around masculine is pulling their gun
out and putting it on
but but it's you're right the spike
thing is is a great one you said it you
know where it's like you know what I
used to be reasonable now no vaxes how's
that sound I don't care if I can polio
leave me alone that's that's everything
that I am today is a result of like the
past three years right it's like you
know a lot of people don't like me oh
you're an [__] why do you curse all
the time man I try to be reasonable with
these [__] [__] them now you
know what I mean [__] them all and I you
know at one point I was I would try to
be reasonable even with like with your
standard Republicans you know what I
mean because I'm like oh we're kind of
friends you know what I mean like you
know I'm not I'm not really one of you
but you know we're moving kind of in the
same general direction like a lot of
those people I can't even associate with
anymore and I can't even tolerate
because
you know it's just uh you get really
tired of that kind of [__]
um and there's a lot of that in uh what
was the the coven movement that has now
morphed into like this uh this like new
conservative bubble on uh or steer on on
social media and it's like
it's
um just incredibly annoying and now I'm
just like you know it's now I I truly
see the problem is we have two shitty
options I love that you guys had South
Park at the beginning
um it's one of my favorite shows one of
my favorite episodes is the douchebag
and the turd sandwich you know I like I
don't I don't think there's a better
example for American politics than that
episode well we say it all the time we
we talk about the unit party all the
time we're done with all these [__]
people because none of these people it's
the same thing we talk about Trump it's
like what Trump do Trump warps beat this
vaccine he didn't [__] do anything
about it either none of these people
care and that's the truth and look I'm
not saying politicians should care but
at least politicians used to at least
try to get their vote but now like
voting is basically meaningless you know
you know Mitch McConnell's gonna win no
matter what the [__] happens and you
know and the trust and the trust level
right now confidence level in anyone
related to the government is so low that
now it's it's it's so easy for that's
why they'll rally around someone like
Ian because it's literally this you hear
the story and then it's like America you
have a choice right now guy with the
cool beard you didn't know existed until
an hour ago
or the government that had a pedophile
Island
who do you want to buy a t-shirt from
you go you know what let me scoop up
look I got a niece you know what I mean
and she goes to the gym let me get two
of them shots it's like it's pretty
they're making the choice a little too
easy at this point and I like like
people are starting to check out but
unfortunately I just these two parties
are always it's always going to be
they're always going to flip a little
bit back and forth and a little bit back
and forth and just keep each other going
and I don't know but in the day all
these [__] same clowns on the right
were saying like you should still get
Voxer nude and stupid Ben Shapiro having
a fake apologize [__] all these people
you know honestly [__] them I don't care
and I I witnessed that and in my in my
rise in that like in that Arena you know
through covid pushed me into that like
conservative hero arena for a while
right
and then they realize like I stopped
getting invited to Turning Point events
and stuff like that because I was like
you know first of all I was I was the
only [__] not like walking around in
a [__] Blazer um join the club Bud we
don't get invited to any of that stuff
anymore either we actively get we
actively get pushed out killing people
there
um yeah no but yeah I love going to
those things and going I don't like none
of y'all yeah
I really don't like you people you
[__] losers even with running for
politics you know I ran I ran for
Congress and
you know it's like I really thought like
all right there's enough of a GOP base
of people who are
not [__] right you know what I mean
like just who understands that you know
the GOP as it exists you know might
represent some of their values but
really doesn't give a [__] about them
and these are people who kind of I don't
know they were the the same people who
resisted covet you know the early
adopters right so
you know and and I run and the GOP is as
bad if not worse than the DNC because
these people are the they're
professional losers at this point yeah
they they always come up short it's like
you know they always fight but it's like
man not enough votes to stop the bill or
you know like not enough votes to to get
you know elected you know that's that's
the GOP in New Jersey is man we put up a
good fight we'll get them next year
we'll get them next year and now and you
listen to like the gop's messaging now
about like voter Integrity they're like
we're just gonna ballot Vote or ballot
Harvest harder and it's like that's your
strategy I know what you're gonna do
with that you're gonna lose again and
say next year just like you've been
saying every time and you you guys are
fine with the way it's going you know
the the GOP talking points
you know they wanted me because it was
you know I'm sitting down in the primary
and they already had their guy but you
know they're like all right well you
know if you want the GOP support you
know X Y and Z you know and it was like
you know we have to get behind Ukraine
and I was like no
oh yeah I got blue dad an event for that
like that's awesome you know and I it
because this was I mean the event was
hilarious I you know we got there with
and it's me it's the uh you know the the
vanilla sandwich or the vanilla Wonder
Bread here and you know and the other
generic you know Republican white guy
and uh
they they give us this introduction it's
like a county event
um and it's the you know start of the
primary season and they have this woman
come up from Ukraine and it's like the
beginning of like oh my God Russia's
invading like when when you know when 99
of the people will buy it
um and I was like no you know so she
gets up she does this whole thing and
she talks about it and they put up a
Ukrainian flag behind us uh and we all
give our speeches and in my speech I
said you know I said I don't know about
anybody else in here I said but I only
like an American flag on my wall behind
me yes um and I got food and and I was
like listen I said you can you guys can
all you can always can all boo me for
that I said but you know your country
has been put last your neighborhoods
have been put last your families have
been put last because of policies like
this and I was like everybody wants to
save the world I said but look at our
neighborhoods and they all looked at me
like idiots because they knew I was
right but of course and that's and
that's it's that blind you there's
certain things that are uniparty
mentality uniparty mental it's like if
you create things another one when you
talk about Ops it's like really so we
all of us we just all agree we're all in
agreement we're all on the same side of
us yeah right away yep well and it can't
and it can't get we can't get abortion
right or we can't get anything we can't
get those hot button issues right now
there's five or ten hot button issues
but when it comes to [__] War we're
there you know what I mean like 95
Russia bad let's do it no matter what
the consequences are no I mean well it's
also sleight of hand because like even
the Republicans now this is how you know
it's all one big party they they 100
agree on Ukraine rubber stamped that
[__] whatever whatever it takes blah
blah blah Slava Ukrainian all that [__]
uh but then the Republicans are gonna
write this narrative about how
rebellious they were now that they have
the house yeah and it's like so they're
doing the whole dude we're trying to
abolish the IRS and income tax all
together and just have a national sales
tax Acts were so based and Dave Smith
brought it up he's like okay but when
you have the house and the Senate yeah
and you and the White House you were
pushing space force and now now all of a
sudden now that we know it's going to
get defeated we're like bro I went in
there and I fought hard for that [__]
tax bill bro I wanted to get ready
they're the professional losers yes and
that's that that tweet pirate I think
Dave Smith tweeted it or whatever yeah
that was that like that's a perfect
[__] example of it though because
they will and they'll sell that and then
guess what when they lose control
they'll campaign that they fought on it
yes they'll take more money from you
because as soon as they lose their
messaging for fundraising starts right
back over of course and it's just it's
just pulling more money pulling more
money and they know the Republican party
that bleeds the middle class that
doesn't have big [__] corporate
donors that bleeds the middle class
while they they make you pay for the war
that they're fighting against a friend
and they're just you know and the friend
is you know that's Court that's
corporate money that's yeah the
Democrats have money for days and days
and days and days and days but the
Republican money the people that sell
hope to all these Americans and these
are all good Americans they might not be
you know all there but they're they're
good-hearted people and
they're just donating their money away
at least Vince McMahon just charges 100
bucks a ticket yeah you know what I mean
and then I can go in and I go watch
people fake fight and I know everybody's
kind of in on it buy a t-shirt get a
chili dog drink a beer go home and go
hey you know what 20 bucks for parking
it wasn't bad I feel less raped Than I
Do by my government
yeah it's a really good it's true and
and that's and that's you're right and
that's and that's basically where we are
it's like the Ukraine thing I'm so I
mean I'm giving you that you create
things awesome I'm glad you don't go
[__] themselves because that's the same
thing it's like going back to that like
Ukraine literally they they some people
go like oh they installed the bad faith
actor they literally installed the guy
who was an actor and and now we're like
okay listen I I my point is it's like a
bad actor a bad actor I don't I know I
am not on cocaine yeah okay buddy sure
you're not sniffles look I don't give a
[__] if you do cocaine cocaine's fun
sometimes however it's like also yeah
[__] president bathroom break over
here
it looks like he needs like a club soda
got some Wicked drip going oh man why do
you have a glass table top in your war
room
I could just get you the Mach 3 razors
why do you want individual ones
but no it's it's and it's it it's you
know it's it's like that man it's they
they tell you this and then you look we
just showed Nikki Haley's gonna run
World economic for him Nikki Haley ooh
yay woo wonderful who gives a [__] all
of these P all of these people it's the
same thing when it comes to all World
economic Forum Henry Kissinger like old
school like just it's just it's yeah it
it is like and you know it's we always
tell people like the best thing you can
do is your local government bro get
local government people that are going
to do [__] because that's all you can do
because that affects your life and you
of course you know that affects your
life more than the federal any federal
policy does because they're the ones
that are going to come and you know
arrest you they're the ones are gonna
[__] change the locks on your
buildings they're the ones at the end of
the day that when push comes to shove
might come and take your [__] guns
you know and and that's you know if
there's one that well I learned that
halfway through you know I when I ran
for congress I'm like you know you know
my line of thought was like all right
like I'm just tired of reacting to
government so like maybe I'll maybe I'll
get in there and at least shake [__] up
um you know and
I get in and I'm like wait a second you
know even if I do get elected like I'm
just gonna be like one of 400 plus just
idiots like yeah what am I gonna do
throw my votes at like you know again
like one of my favorite you know one of
the only politicians I ever liked Ron
Paul yes Ron Paul 2012 baby we're 20
we're around pop 22. oh way back that
was my first big heartbreak that was my
first big heartbreak in life where you
went oh it's all Rick like I always knew
it was Rick but it was like oh it's all
just [__] Super Rich there's not a
chance but you know a guy like Ron Paul
you know he he fought his his you know
his best and he he was awesome but what
changed he wasn't able to stop any of
this you know so I was thinking I'm like
man I really should have ran for local
government because I see the power in it
like yo if you can get a couple people
on your school board you can pump the
brakes on the crazy with your kids in
your town you know if you can get a
couple people on your Town Council if
you get somebody elected as a sheriff
um and somebody who has the balls to say
no when it's when it's not the easy
thing to do you know somebody who's
going to say I'm not going to enforce
those gun laws that's that's the only
thing that you should be focused on like
I'm I'm convinced at this point that
there's there's no putting the brakes on
the federal government at all no they're
gonna they're gonna do whatever they
want to do
it's not it's not going to stop the only
way that you can stop it is you have to
build some sort of foundation at the
local levels first people have to get
control of their neighborhoods their
towns you know and and pay attention
there stand their ground there and if
enough places do that in this country
you'll see you'll see a shift I I agree
with that I would also add to that
though like even if people aren't you
know there's plenty of people out there
that don't have what it takes don't have
maybe not the Charisma or they don't
have the connection or they just don't
have what it takes to get involved like
locally as far as being a candidate I
think uh you know we've seen with like
Alex Stein and some of those guys even
if you're not going to do a comedy bit
but just going and speaking at these
things like it's one thing to have a guy
like you run it would be a whole lot
better if a guy like you runs you're
going to town like City you know Hall
meetings or whatever or Town Council
meetings and like other people are there
to reinforce and kind of go yeah yeah
this guy's [__] right dude like you
know what I mean when you go up solo and
you like I'm going to stand up and speak
I think a lot of people do that it's I
think more people need to treat it like
when people used to do like Open Mic
bringer shows and comedies like no can
you bring like four or five friends to
just like I gotta fill out the audience
and get some people children you know
what I mean like it's gonna help me out
you know it's it's people have this this
capacity to complain about everything
but you know
you have a certain Duty like if you
really want this whole thing to work
right if you really believe in you know
of America land of the free the whole
kind of deal you know you've got a
certain amount of personal
responsibility to show up at that
[__] meeting you know and even if
even if you're not gonna say anything
just show up and say yeah I stand with I
agree with this you know what I mean
like you've got a civic duty you know
and it's you can't you can't be
concerned about politics but not
sacrificing at least something and that
doesn't have to be doesn't mean you got
to show up every night but you got to be
involved in in your area you have to be
providing some sort of
value into your community if you're
expecting anything out of it and we've
got a lot of people who they think
that's just sharing stuff on social
media and that's like no because we all
know the difference between getting [__]
tweeted at us that's mean which we've
all had yeah versus somebody shouting
something or at least saying something
to you very definitively to your face
it's a different thing and then maybe if
there's 10 or 11 people definitively
saying something to your [__] face in
a meeting like people think you could
just call somebody the fsler on Twitter
and be like my job here is done and
you're like no he's just gonna mute you
and move on they can't mute you in a
town hall meeting you can go there and
go no I think you're an F slur stop
[__] up the schools there you go all
right thank you for your time like it's
a little more jarring to have somebody
say some [__] to you you're like oh okay
it is especially because at the local
level these people live in your
communities yeah I mean like so when you
when you show that frustration or that
anger or that discontent they're gonna
feel that a lot more than if you like
but Nancy Pelosi's expensive ice cream
she shouldn't give a [__] she doesn't
care she doesn't you know like she
probably saw that and laughed her ass
off and just like went and got another
one like that's that's not that type of
outrage isn't gonna get anything but you
can go to your school board with [__]
20 people that care about what the [__]
the kids are being taught and be
outraged and at least have your voice
heard if nothing else
um and have them consider like maybe we
shouldn't be such [__] because these
people live like right down the street
from us
um you know maybe maybe at least we'll
we'll compromise you know you're not
always going to get it 100 your way you
know but I I think that's one of the
things that's most important for people
that you actually want to if you
actually want something out of this
you've got to contribute and there's a
huge portion of people who just don't
well it's it's it's you know it's
talking about like the January 6th is a
great example right so January 6th thing
happens and then these these politicians
on both sides are posting Lindsey Graham
we should just shoot them you know well
yeah he was he said it more gay but you
know what I mean and and Lindsey Graham
wants a lot of other people to kill
people for him yeah I know so well Putin
yeah
he wants everyone to kill people for him
I just think the boys are so cute anyway
um he he you know but but then then this
shows these pictures of like look at
that look look look at these government
officials in fear I'm like you you know
this [__] this whole country was founded
on them being afraid of us right yes
they're supposed to be afraid of us yeah
those Native Americans heard one [__]
gun go off they were like Jesus Christ
what the [__] was that yeah so this
whole this whole thing started with a
boot with boom sticks all right let's
not [__] forget that and and and and
now and now it's like no we should feel
safe in our palaces right [__] off well
that's that's the crazy thing is they've
convinced people they've convinced a
large portion of this like the NPC
population that like
that they shouldn't ever feel threatened
as politicians and it's like no like
this country was founded on the idea
that politicians should always be on
their toes because that's how you keep
people on their best behavior if you
know that you can get [__] up for what
you're doing you're not going to do bad
[__]
but they've layered themselves behind so
many lies and so much bureaucracy and
they have people so distracted that it's
like oh oh oh you're frustrated that I'm
teaching your your children about about
anal sex in fourth grade and you want
you want to hurt me because of that like
oh my God I'm just trying to be and it's
that that virtue signaling that they
hide behind it's like yeah I want to
punch you in your [__] face dude yeah
you're right I want to hit you and
that's the thing and more people are
rising up in this country and and being
like pointing the guys like him and
going I also want him to punch you in
the face
emotion I'm gonna smoke a cigarette
facing this way in case in case yeah
I think more people are starting it with
the like Libs of tic tac and the
groomers and like the Gaze against
groomers like there's a lot of like
publicly shits like it's surfacing now
all these Tick Tock videos and all this
[__] that's not fake it's yeah these are
real teachers and I think you are
starting to see a little I've seen it
already at least as far as the school
meetings go a lot more parents showing
up to those lately yeah there's been a
lot of [__] very angry no let's be
loud a lot more dads showing up which
has made a big impact because a man
screamed look sorry ladies but a man
screaming in your face is gonna be more
scary than a woman screaming in your
face and they're panicking now because
it used to be like all right well we'll
do the whole you know we can always go
with the whole white supremacist angle
but now it's a lot of Hispanic and black
that's true and now they're showing up
and going hey what is this [__] my
daughter came home with hey yo dead ass
dog I got my daughter coming home
telling me she got boys in the bathroom
and [__] you got me [__] up and
they're like uh we're not that's one of
the Beautiful Things is yeah once they
once they encroach so much be like there
it there is some sort of unification
because they they're very good at
dividing everybody right you know what I
mean like whatever they play their
[__] race and religion and [__]
all this [__] games you know but
there's certain things like if you come
after people's children at least it
should like it should follow that
everybody's not gonna be okay with that
you know like there's no there's no
cultural differences you know unless
you're talking about like marrying young
wives over in whatever but you know even
you even saw the Muslims up in Michigan
you know they
they showed up there's videos of them
yeah in these towns and they were like
you're gonna teach our kids about sex
yeah this but like I'm sorry you mean
the Muslim you mean the Muslim face of
white supremacy yeah exactly so and
that's the problem now it's like a video
game or an app that just keeps crashing
the desk yeah because the code is like
it's like they patch to the code too
many times they updated the game too
many times and now they're like well
we've empowered these Muslims too much
and we've empowered the gays too much
and now we've got sort of a problem here
yeah and it's like now what do we do we
can't go out and call the [__] Arabs
racist like what do we do and you can't
call the gays dramatic so what are you
gonna do and it's like all right which
one of you guys told the Arab guy you're
gonna molest this kid because
we have a real problem on our hands but
but it's true it's it's really it's
really turned into this weird like
they've pushed that's a promise like
they push it too far they always do they
always go too far where like most normal
people don't care about their they don't
care about the race they don't care
about who they're [__] they're just
like hey man are you trying to [__] my
kids and they're like they're just
calling some local Democrat election
picture and going so what do I do do I
let them kill the gays I don't care or
do I let the gays rape the Muslims I
don't I'm good because the handbook has
all kinds of conflicting info at this
point none of them are white I don't
know who to play and the and the
Democrat training videos from the 90s
and it's Al Gore being like ah this is
Vice President Al Gore yeah you might be
worrying about how you're going to budge
uh balance the deficit this year and we
all just laugh at that old video right
that's cute deficit that's Hillary okay
so remember the 90s I'm gonna now I'm
gonna ask some Jim bro questions because
I have to ask okay all right quick okay
Max deadlift
uh 655. Jesus
I just did 525 I'm very happy about that
nice that's and anything anything north
of 400 is good 525 one rep I got so far
so that's [__] huge okay second squat
555 [__] 405.
um God damn it uh what did you think he
was did you think you were no but I
thought it was closer okay uh you
thought you were going to be close yeah
I don't know I don't know if that was
just glamor muscles look at this guy
it's probably glamor month it's not now
I know it's not bench or 15. Jesus I
just did 360. no 375 for one rep they
selling these I just recently tore my
pack to it
oh look I can see what I can see it was
a little one it was a little one wasn't
too bad it was just just a little guy
yeah so well New Jersey I can wasn't one
of those ones where you see like the
like the uh
the Cody Rhodes thing that he ripped the
Peck off yeah yeah well I can see why
the the New Jersey police were resorting
to fines yes you know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna write that you know what I'm
gonna do when I see that [__] he
opens his gym one more [__] time he's
gonna I'm writing some [__] whoo you
were getting some summonses Bob
you're gonna go talk to a judge oh man
I'll mail him I'll mail him I'm gonna
mail them I'm not gonna actually you
know what it's my lunch break oh can
Susan do it I don't think you'll hit a
girl can Susan do it
Jesus [__] Christ all right but that
you're an animal dude like honestly I
watch you doing [__] three reps what
was it overhead press of like 235
yeah that's that's my favorite list
oh my god oh they hurt so much um
Ultimate Warrior stuff yeah ultimate I
actually tried it when I whenever I try
to do that as much as possible because
I've always just had the really sad
slopey hunchy kind of body so when I
started working out I was trying to do a
lot of the you know that'll do with the
shoulders look at least more like a
human adult man and also you know I
don't like this guy coming on he makes
my beard look like a [__] bitch-ass
beard compared this guy's [__] beard
is like oh [__] yeah this looks cool but
it also I feel like that thing's
probably a pain in the ass is it oh
hard to maintain it's like when you see
a chick who's got gorgeous long hair
yeah and you're like you know that's a
[__] pain in the ass fire though
that's not easy yeah
it's actually not too bad but I ride a
motorcycle so it's it's [__] up a lot
of times of course yeah I've just I've
just resorted to like you know [__]
yeah put as many rubber bands in it as I
can so [__] you're on the highway and
you see something that looks like Cousin
It sneezing but it's just on the [__]
road you're like what the [__]
oh [__] Ian man thank you for coming on
what are we telling people about where
are we going what are we doing yeah how
are we supporting uh you can follow
everything I'm doing on social media Ian
Smith Fitness that's on Instagram and
Twitter that's where all the updates are
at and I've been a good boy recently so
I'm not not too Shadow banned so you
should be able to find me without typing
in that whole name you want yeah or yeah
you were a good boy you literally said
hi to Phil Murphy's wife's boyfriend
it's pretty funny it's [__] killed me
by the way that was hilarious oh [__]
all right I'm putting that I got a shot
of them still yep there it is in the
chat hey man thank you so much you're
welcome on whenever dude that was a lot
of fun seriously you come on whatever
anything you want to plug you you come
on all right cool man thanks guys take
it easy so much see you later
man he was fun gonna kick this ass Bryce
[__] just would have slapped him if
he said anything anything
he would he would throw us out the
window
what an animal I'll be honestly I
wouldn't be confident with him with my
gun no because I feel like he could
probably take three good rounds it's
like you know because I'm not that great
of a shot Jesus Christ God forbid I had
to reload
um no that was great he's fun dude bro
that Ukraine thing that what that's my
favorite thing he said when he said [__]
you crane can I be honest huh when
because Royce put this one together and
I was thinking all right should be all
right this was not one of the interviews
I was expecting to be this fun yeah he's
fun he's a fun he's actually a fun guy
that's a dude you want to hang out with
right yeah because I was like I will get
him on like my favorite thing was like
you're in the military prison for five
years yeah I was like all right I like
this guy that [__] rules yeah no he
um I don't know man if there's people
you have on that you're like you know oh
it's gonna be and then if people have on
the all right well I think it'll be okay
like we just admired him for what he did
yeah what a great story and like but
he's covered him so much on the show
we're like of course we want to have him
on but I was like I don't know it's
gonna be like because you get people on
sometimes and they're not they're just
kind of not fun but he's fun bro he's
he's he's good man he's a good good dude
really did stand up for what he believed
in and you know the whole the whole like
the red dope have a beer with him you
know he's the kind of guy you go out and
have one vodka with no additives in it
with no no no buddy just beat a DUI
homie drinks oh okay that's true and he
beat it which makes him even more of a
Chad by the way he beat a DUI